تمت إدارة علاقة إيران بالقاعدة
والحفاظ عليها من قبل
قوة غطاء محرك السيارة لقوات الحرس الثوري الإسلامي
منذ تسعينيات القرن الماضي ، ولا تزال قوات كودز
شريكها الأساسي
داخل إيران نفسها ، وأعتقد أنه من
المهم اعتبار أن قاسم سليماني
لم يكن رئيس
البضاعة.  القوة
في هذا الوقت لكنك تنظر إلى
سلفه وحيدي وهذا
مؤشر على أن علاقة قوة السلع
مع القاعدة ظلت
ثابتة منذ تلك الفترة أه حتى
اليوم
بالنسبة لمدى تلك العلاقة
أعتقد أنه من المهم أيضًا أن نلاحظ  هذا
siphoto بحث عن ملاذ داخل إيران
نفسها ، وفي الواقع تم وضعه قيد الاحتجاز الفضفاض من
قبل الحكومة الإيرانية في
وقت ما ثم أطلق سراحه لاحقًا
ومنحه إه مزيدًا من الحرية داخل إيران
نفسها ، وهذا مؤشر على أنه شعر
بالأمان والراحة في الذهاب إلى إيران
لإجراء  أنشطة القيادة